حقيقه بالعين المجرده ما شهدناه على ارض
الواقع وما سمعناه من قصص حقيقه يعني شيء
مؤثر جدا يعني هذه من اصعب التغطيات التي
اقوم بها
منذ زمن طويل لم لم اشهد مثل هذه التغطيه
لا حجم دوار ولا ماساه ولا معانا مشاعر
مختلطه يعني هنا في هذه مواقع الدمار طبعا
الكاميرا الان هنا في احد الاماكن في
مدينه اضنه القصص التي نسمعها يوميا يعني
قصص محزنه جدا قبل قليل ساروي اخر قصه
سمعتها من احد رجال الانقاذ من هذا الموقع
الذي نتابع منه
الان ناديل خلال الساعات الماضيه يعني
الليله الماضيه حتى ساعات الفجر تم انتشال
خمس
جثث او خمس جثث
لاشخاص تعتقد او تعتقد طواقم من الانقاذ
انهم لعائله واحده
اب وام وطفلين وسيده كبيره بالعمر يعتقد
انها جدت الطفلين احد الاشخاص الذي شارك
في هذه العمليه اخبرني انه شاهد ان جثمان
الطفل عندما وصلوا اليه كانه كان كان
جاثيا وقد انحنى اثناء محاولته وبدا
الدمار
بدا دمار المبنى كان جاثيا على ركبتيه
ومنكمشا بشكل كبير جدا وبقي على هذه
الحاله مع الاسف حتى وصول طواقم الانقاذ
اليه صباح هذا اليوم او فجر هذا اليوم